- What are we doing?
- Tinikling?
- Tinikling.
- Sounds like tickling.
- Tickling
(laughs)
(Filipino Tinikling music playing)
- Whoa!
I like this.
- Have you ever gotten snipped before?
- Ohh.
- For sure?
- I can't wait to trip and
fall and break my face.
- [Ned] This is really dangerous.
- Is that it?
It's so easy.
- It's like a workout.
It's like doing Jacob's
ladders in football.
- I know how to do the
Electric Slide, you know?
- How hard can it be?
- Do people get hurt a lot
when they first try this?
- Uh...
- No?
Yes.
Okay, he nodded yes.
(laughs)
- Do you wanna hold my hand?
- Not really.
- Shut up!
(laughs)
Just hold my hand!
- You're slamming very strong,
like there's a lot of power.
- Seems like with an intent.
- Ahh!
- Let's go.
- Ah!
- Ready, go.
- Ah (beep)!
- Rhythm!
- Ahh!
- Oh, my god!
- You gotta keep the tempo going, man!
You almost took my feet out!
- You gotta be kidding me y'all.
- Well don't say that.
- These guys, I don't know.
This is really not my thing.
- People who can do this are a genius.
- That's (beep) Filipinos, man.
Okay?
- I'm scared, I don't like it!
(laughs)
I'm scared!
- Did I do it?
Was I doing it?
- I think I was better when I was drunk.
Like I don't know how
that's even possible.
- Clap, clap, clap, clap.
- Oh, oh, no!
- Woo!
Freestyle.
Oh god.
(laughs)
- Ready?
Ready?
- Why'd you hit me?
I didn't even get in!
- It was harder than I thought, for sure.
But I think with a little bit of practice,
it's pretty fun actually.
- I feel you have to
be one with the bamboo.
- Yeah, you have to be
totally one with the bamboo.
- And I was not?
- Like the bamboo and you
are the same.
- They're hardcore, for sure.
- They're (beep) hardcore.
Even their simple ceremonial
dances could kill you.
This dance could kill you.
And they have children doing it.
It could kill you.
- If you were doing it near a volcano.
Do they have volcanoes in the Philippines?
Yeah!
- Most places have volcanoes.